.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Immer am Donnerstag wirft Marina
Fuhrer die Profi-Pastamaschine an.
Die Pasta bringt Geld,
Selbstständigkeit
und ist Teil
von Marinas Bäuerinnenkonzept.
* Muntere Gitarrenklänge *
Jeder hat ein bestimmtes Bild
von einer Bäuerin im Kopf.
Aber letztlich ...
Ich kenne
sehr viele junge Bäuerinnen.
Sie gehen alle ihren eigenen Weg.
Es gibt sehr viele verschiedene,
spannende Konzepte.
Man benötigt schon
etwas Mut und Selbstvertrauen.
Man muss in das Ganze hineinwachsen
und lernen, zu sagen:
"Ich bin eine andere Art von
Bäuerin. Ich mache es so und so."
Marina Fuhrer
gehört zu einer neuen Generation
von Bäuerinnen und Landwirtinnen: gut
ausgebildet und mit eigenen Ideen.
Doch sie betreten eine Welt,
in der Frauen
lange nicht wahrgenommen wurden
und wo ihre Arbeit
kaum Anerkennung erhielt.
Eine Welt, in der Land und Geld
den Männern vorbehalten waren.
* Spannungsvolle Trommelklänge *
Die Arbeit auf dem Hof Girentobel
im Zürcher Tösstal beginnt früh.
So.
Oh, habe ich dich nass gespritzt?
* Marina schnalzt. *
Komm her.
Dabei war Marina Fuhrer
bis vor Kurzem
nicht unbedingt Frühaufsteherin.
Sie war stellvertretende
Geschäftsleiterin einer Drogerie.
Ich war kein Kind,
das Bäuerin werden wollte.
Ich bin in die Landwirtschaft
hineingerutscht.
Ich wusste immer,
dass ich mal Mutter werden will.
Aber ich wollte nie Bäuerin werden.
Niemals.
Auch meine Eltern hätten nie
gedacht, dass ich mal Bäuerin werde.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Beat Fuhrer ist der Hofbesitzer
und Betriebsleiter.
Dafür hat er eine dreijährige Lehre
als Landwirt abgeschlossen.
Mit der Heirat wurde Marina Fuhrer
zur Frau eines Bauern
und damit zur Bäuerin.
Sie entschied, berufsbegleitend
die Bäuerinnenschule zu absolvieren -
eine hauswirtschaftliche Ausbildung.
Ihr Mann kümmert sich um die Kühe.
Auch um Melody,
die bald ein Kälbchen bekommen soll.
Ich bin nicht
auf einem Bauernhof aufgewachsen.
Kühe kenne ich
erst durch ihn so richtig.
Ich habe immer noch einen
gewissen Respekt vor diesen Tieren -
einfach aufgrund der Masse.
Eine solche Kuh
könnte mich locker umrennen.
Ich habe eigentlich
keine Angst vor den Kühen,
aber ich bin zufrieden
mit meinen Kälbchen.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Im Stall hilft Marina
meistens nur am Morgen.
Ich sagte immer, dass ich ihn
unterstütze, so gut es geht.
Aber ich stehe nicht
von morgens bis abends im Stall.
So geht sie weiterhin in die Drogerie
zur Arbeit - immer am Mittwoch.
Dieser Tag ist mir wirklich heilig.
Ich sagte von Anfang an,
dass ich noch mindestens einen Tag
in der Drogerie arbeiten will.
Ich mag meinen Beruf
und meine Arbeitskollegen sehr gern.
Ich arbeite schon
sehr lange in diesem Betrieb
und es gefällt mir total.
Hallo, Lorin. Stehst du auf?
Wer ist denn hier?
Hallo.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Du bist gerade erst aufgewacht
und es ist schon so viel los.
Seit gut 20 Monaten
gehört auch Lorin zur Familie Fuhrer.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Guten Morgen.
Hallo, Männlein.
Hallo.
Schon vor der Heirat
haben die beiden abgemacht,
wie sie die Arbeit aufteilen.
Die Devise: Niemand muss
etwas tun, was er nicht gerne tun.
Auch nicht den Stall.
(Beat) Das war für mich
eigentlich kein Problem.
Es war nie ein Thema, dass sie
auf dem Hof mitarbeiten muss.
Ich plante das Ganze schon immer so,
dass es ohne eine Frau funktioniert,
die auf dem Hof mitarbeitet.
Ich wollte einfach jemanden,
der versteht, was ich tue,
und der mich etwas unterstützt.
Sonst wird es sehr schwierig.
Wenn jemand
so stark ortsgebunden ist
und die Partnerin
das nicht mitmacht,
kann es fast nicht klappen.
Jetzt kannst du trinken, Lorin.
- Nochmals.
Jetzt kannst du trinken.
* Lorin plappert. *
Dass es so gut klappen würde,
war in den letzten Monaten
allerdings nicht selbstverständlich.
Ein Schicksalsschlag hat die
gewohnte Arbeitsteilung auf dem Hof
auf den Kopf gestellt.
Wir übernahmen den Hof
vor einem Jahr, im Januar 2021.
Wir hatten das weitere Vorgehen
ziemlich genau geplant.
Mein Papa war damals 58, nein, 59.
Nein, er war noch 58.
Wir wussten, dass er noch ein paar
Jahre arbeiten durfte bzw. musste.
Ein paar Monate später
hatte er eine Hirnblutung
und bei ihm
wurde Krebs diagnostiziert.
Danach starb er.
Sein Tod ist noch nicht lange her.
Das warf die ganze Sache
über den Haufen
und für einen Moment
standen wir vor dem Nichts.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Familie und Freunde halfen uns,
den Laden
bis Weihnachten zu schmeissen.
Wir wussten, dass wir
bis Weihnachten durchhalten mussten,
da es dann
auf dem Hof ruhiger werden
und wir Zeit haben würden,
zu planen, wie es weitergehen soll.
Bis jetzt haben wir das
ganz gut hingekriegt.
Da Papa nicht mehr da ist,
ist Marina stärker in den Stall
involviert als geplant.
Auf einem Hof
sind alle aufeinander angewiesen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Auf einem Bauernhof
gibt es immer etwas zu tun,
aber man muss Prioritäten setzen.
Was ist einem wichtig?
Lorin und Marina stehen sehr weit
oben auf der Prioritätenliste,
wenn nicht sogar zuoberst.
Der Rest muss halt warten.
In der derzeitigen Situation
ist Lorin
natürlich eine totale Freude.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Der Hof Girentobel ist stattlich.
47 ha Land,
1'000 Hühner,
45 Kühe
und noch einmal so viele Rinder.
Und es gibt nur einen Landwirt.
Marina Fuhrer und die neue Hof-
mitarbeiterin Ramona Frauchiger
sind allein, als bei Kuh Melody
die Wehen einsetzen.
Wir warten darauf,
dass die Fruchtblase ...
... platzt.
Dann sehen wir,
ob das Kalb richtig liegt
und ich werde Beat anrufen.
Wenn er in der Nähe ist,
wird er kurz vorbeikommen.
Ramona sah schon einige Kühe kalben.
Sie wuchs auf einem Bauernhof auf.
Du hast auch schon einem Rind
beim Kalben geholfen, was?- Ja.
Ich rufe Beat an.
Die Blase
ist immer noch geschlossen,
aber Ramona hat ein Züngeln gesehen.
Müssen wir die Blase öffnen?
Können wir noch abwarten? Gut.
Die Klauen liegen richtig,
da bin ich mir sicher.
Okay.
Kommst du irgendwann?
Gut.
Tschüss.
Wenn wir das Köpfchen sehen,
können wir die Blase öffnen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Warten.
Komm auf diese Seite.
- Okay.
Du kannst den Kopf halten
und das hier hochschieben.
Komm, nochmals. Ja, gut, super.
Jetzt musst du den Kopf hochhalten.
Komm, pressen.
- Ja, gut!
Super. Ziehen, ziehen.
* Marina und Ramona
ächzen angestrengt. *
Ja, und nach vorn,
nach vorn mit ihm.
Komm.
Ja. So.
Komm. Ja.
Super.
Gut. Gut gemacht.
Du auch, Melody.
Du hast es auch gut gemacht.
Ich hole etwas zu Trinken.
Ja, es ist da.
Ramona und ich zogen es raus.
Machst du den Trank
oder soll ich mich darum kümmern?
Welchen muss ich nehmen?
Gut, das machen wir.
Gut, wir haben alles im Griff.
Tschüss.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Das ist gut, nicht wahr?
So.
Komm, wir schauen uns
das Kälbchen an.
Gut gemacht.
* Lachen *
Na, du.
Habt ihr es gut gemacht?
- Ja.
Hattet ihr ein bisschen Action?
Aber wir haben es geschafft.
(Lorin) Hey.
- Ja.
Gut, nicht wahr?
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Muhen *
Ui-ui-ui.
* Dynamische Musik *
Landwirtinnen und Betriebsleiterinnen
sind in der Schweizer Landwirtschaft
selten.
Nur 7 % der Betriebe
werden von Frauen geführt.
Der Grund dafür ist einfach:
Für viele Bauern
war es lange fast undenkbar,
Hof und Land einer Frau zu übergeben,
einer Tochter statt einem Sohn.
(Frau) Ich war überhaupt nicht dafür
vorgesehen, den Hof zu übernehmen.
Aber weder mein Bruder
noch meine Schwester wollten ihn.
Als sich meine Eltern
pensionieren liessen, dachte ich:
"Wieso sollen wir das
alles weggeben?"
Mein Vater sprach nie viel darüber,
aber für ihn war es schon
eine Enttäuschung, eine Art Trauer,
dass der Sohn
den Hof doch nicht übernahm.
Es ist einfach tief verwurzelt,
dass der Familienbesitz
dem Sohn übergeben wird.
Da gab es schon
Enttäuschung und Schmerz.
Nun ist es Anne,
die das Erbe der Familie
Tag für Tag weiterleben lässt.
Der Hof ist
auf Milchproduktion ausgerichtet
und liegt im waadtländischen
Corcelles-le-Jorat.
Sechs Jahre ist es her, seit der
Vater ihr die Zügel übergeben hat.
Ich bin einfach gern
meine eigene Chefin
und ich bin gern Unternehmerin.
Ich liebe die Milch,
den Käse und die ganze Kultur,
die es rund um die Milch gibt.
Es bedeutet mir viel,
das weiterzuführen,
was schon viele Generationen vor mir
gemacht haben.
Annes Enthusiasmus hilft ihr durch
den harten und arbeitsreichen Alltag.
Wenn man es nicht selbst erlebt,
kann man sich kaum vorstellen,
was es heisst, mit Kühen zu leben.
Man kann einfach nie weg.
Will man weg, passiert immer etwas.
Irgendwann gibt man es auf
und geht nicht mehr weg.
Es gibt keinen Tag
ohne Überraschung.
Geht ein Tag ohne Katastrophe
vorbei, denkt man: "Schön."
Das ist eine grosse Einschränkung.
Man ist ein bisschen
eine Gefangene dieser Herde.
Die Einschränkungen sind umso härter,
weil gleichzeitig die Milch
immer schlechter bezahlt wird.
Mit der Milchproduktion aufzuhören,
wäre für mich ein Scheitern.
Das würde heissen,
dass wir es nicht geschafft haben,
unseren Lohn zu verbessern.
Dafür müssen wir uns einsetzen,
damit es in der Schweiz weiterhin
möglich ist, Kühe zu melken.
Tatsächlich geben jedes Jahr fast 750
Landwirte die Milchproduktion auf,
weil es ihnen nicht mehr gelingt,
eine Familie damit durchzubringen.
Est-ce-que je peux vous offrir
quelque crème à café équitable?
Anne Chenevard
will nicht tatenlos zusehen.
Sie engagiert sich im Kampf
um einen fairen Milchpreis.
* Perlende Klavierklänge *
Hinter jedem Liter Milch
steckt viel Arbeit.
Anne Chenevard
schultert diese Last allein.
Und dann gibt es auch noch ihr Leben
als alleinerziehende Mutter.
Ihr Sohn ist zwölf Jahre alt.
Es ist eine enorme Arbeitslast:
einen Betrieb führen,
eine Herde halten,
die ganze Administration,
die immer komplizierter wird,
und parallel dazu die Familie,
um die ich mich kümmere.
Als Betriebsleiterin
macht man viel unsichtbare Arbeit.
Wenn ich im Haus arbeite, muss ich
mich manchmal fast rechtfertigen -
als würde ich nichts tun.
Oft habe ich das Gefühl,
meine Familie und den Haushalt
zu vernachlässigen,
um den Hof zu führen.
Kümmere ich mich
um die Familie, denke ich,
ich vernachlässige den Hof.
Bonjour, maman.
- Bonjour, Lenny, ça va?
Ich denke, viele meiner Kolleginnen
in der Landwirtschaft
fühlen sich ähnlich und glauben,
nirgends zu genügen.
Je te mets du saucisson?
Je te mets trois tranches.
- Oui, vas-y.
Bon appétit.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Chefin eines Landwirtschaftsbetriebes
zu sein,
ist für viele Frauen immer noch
alles andere als selbstverständlich.
Nicht so auf diesem Obstbaubetrieb.
Hier wachsen Aprikosen,
Äpfel, Birnen und Trauben.
In Alines Familie gab es zwei Töchter
und Aline hat, seit sie denken kann,
an der Seite ihres Vaters gearbeitet.
Als er vor fünf Jahren verstarb,
übernahm sie den Betrieb.
Ich bin die Landwirtin,
nicht die Frau von einem.
Die Chefin bin ich.
Auf der landwirtschaftlichen Schule
gab es eigentlich
ziemlich viele Frauen.
Aber es war nicht üblich, dass diese
dann auch den Betrieb übernahmen.
Im Obstanbau war ich
die einzige in der Klasse.
Es gibt schon Frauen
in diesem Metier, aber wenige.
Es sind viele Arbeitsstunden.
Physisch ist es sehr anstrengend.
Ich finde diesen Beruf sehr schön
und man kann ihn als Frau ausüben.
Manchmal muss man einfach
etwas kreativ sein.
Physisch kann ich
nicht wie ein Mann arbeiten.
Darum brauche ich ein gutes Team.
Ça n'a pas mal poussé, hein?
- Oui.
Vous avez suffisamment de boucles?
War es klar,
dass Sie Angestellte brauchen?
Ja, wegen der Grösse des Betriebs.
Mein Vater
arbeitete mit der Familie,
aber ich habe Personal eingestellt.
Wäre es ohne Männer möglich?
Da ich eine Chefin bin, finde ich
es besser, Männer einzustellen.
Sie können die Arbeiten übernehmen,
die etwas mehr Kraft verlangen.
Auf einem Obstbaubetrieb ist
das Unvorhersehbare allgegenwärtig.
2020 war die Apfelernte
äusserst dürftig.
Darauf folgte 2021
eine lange Frostphase.
Finanziell war ich damals
bereits am Limit.
Es war für mich schwierig,
Frostkerzen zu kaufen.
Erst im letzten Moment
entschied ich mich dafür
und setzte sie eine Nacht lang ein.
Danach benutzte ich Wasser.
Das ist billiger.
Zuerst kämpften wir
nur bei den Aprikosen gegen Frost.
Am Schluss
kämpften wir bei allen Bäumen.
In jenem Jahr
verlor Aline 60 % ihrer Ernte.
Nun hofft sie, mit der
von ihr gegründeten Fruchtsaftmarke
einen Teil des Geldes
wieder hereinzuholen.
Bonjour.
Bonjour, Aline.- Bonjour.
So kann ich
auch die Früchte verwenden,
die mir die Grossverteiler
nicht abnehmen.
Oh, magnifique, des poires William.
Mit den Produkten
verringere ich mein Risiko.
Ich wollte finanziell
breiter aufgestellt sein.
Für den Fall, dass etwas
plötzlich nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich habe niemanden, der mir
finanziell hilft. Ich bin allein.
Aline hat im Bereich Obstbau
viele Abschlüsse in der Tasche.
Dennoch muss sie um ihren Platz
in dieser von Männern geprägten Welt
kämpfen.
Es wäre ideal, wenn ich
etwas mehr Anbaufläche hätte.
Aber meine Kollegen,
die pensioniert werden,
verkaufen ihr Land lieber an Männer,
auch wenn es
direkt an meines grenzt.
Sie sagen,
ich hätte zu wenig Erfahrung,
obwohl ich schon seit 20 Jahren
in diesem Beruf arbeite.
Das ist schon seltsam.
Aber es ist so.
Es gibt auch die väterliche Seite:
"Brauchst du uns?", fragen sie.
Oder: "Sollen wir dir
beim Ausreissen helfen?"
Ich habe einige Telefonnummern
von Leuten, die gerne helfen.
Es ist schön, zu wissen, dass sie
da sind, wenn ich ein Problem habe.
Ja, es gibt
diese beschützende Seite.
Hier sind wir vor meiner Pflanzung.
Ich habe einen Betrieb geerbt,
den mein Vater aufgebaut hat.
Aber nun konnte ich etwas aufbauen,
so, wie ich es wollte.
Hatten Sie denn Zweifel an sich?
Nun, ich bin trotz allem
eine Frau in der Landwirtschaft.
Ich musste mich beweisen. Jetzt
arbeite ich seit fünf Jahren allein.
Eigentlich sollte es nun gut sein,
hoffe ich.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Die Hühner im Zürcher Tösstal
mögen glücklich sein,
doch für die Mehrheit
der Bauernfamilien
wird der Alltag
immer mehr zum Überlebenskampf.
Es gibt nur wenige Betriebe,
die mehr als 70'000 Fr.
Gewinn pro Jahr generieren.
Auch auf dem Hof Girentobel
war das in diesem ersten Jahr
der Übernahme nicht möglich.
Schon seit je
versuchten die Bäuerinnen,
noch etwas Geld dazuzuverdienen.
Im Girentobel sind es die Eier,
mit denen Marina Fuhrer
und ihre Schwiegermutter Heidi Fuhrer
Geschäfte betreiben.
Soll das zu den Backeiern?
Es ist ziemlich gross.
Die Eier, die die Grossverteiler
dem Hof nicht abnehmen,
benutzt Marina Fuhrer für ihre Pasta.
Brucheier sind einerseits Eier,
die einen Riss haben,
aber auch diese Eier hier fallen
bei uns in die Kategorie Brucheier.
Das ist ein schönes Ei,
aber es ist zu gross.
Darin befinden sich
bestimmt auch zwei Eidotter.
Das nimmt uns niemand ab.
Hier ist noch ein Exemplar
mit sehr rauer Schale.
Sie ist fast wie Schmirgelpapier.
Hier haben wir ein kleines Ei,
das auch nicht der Norm entspricht
und daher aussortiert wird.
Von Anfang an verkaufte sich
Marina Fuhrers Pasta sehr gut.
Der Treuhänder empfahl,
eine eigene Firma zu gründen.
Er meinte, er habe
gute Erfahrungen damit gemacht,
wenn die Frauen das Unternehmen
selbst repräsentieren.
Das sorgt für eine andere Energie
als wenn alles
zum selben Unternehmen gehört
und niemand etwas Eigenes hat.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ich habe eine eigene Buchhaltung
und beziehe einen Lohn.
Ich bezahle Beat z.B. auch Miete
für den Produktionsraum,
den ich hier betreibe.
Ich verkaufe die Teigwaren
an Heidis Hofladen.
Gleichzeitig
kaufe ich ihr die Eier ab,
die ich für die Produktion benötige.
Es wird alles gegengerechnet.
Der Hofladen läuft über Heidi,
er ist ihr Business.
Das hier ist mein Business
und der Betrieb ist
nochmals ein anderes Business.
* Dynamische Musik *
Das ist zwar Heidi Fuhrers Business,
aber eine eigene Firma hat sie,
die selbst auf einem Bauernhof
aufgewachsen ist, nicht gegründet.
Ich arbeitete einfach drauflos.
Ich suchte ein zweites Standbein
und so wurde das zu meinem Job.
Aber das war
nicht wirklich so geplant.
Wir waren einfach der Meinung,
dass wir
ein zusätzliches Einkommen brauchen,
damit wir den Hof
nicht aufgeben müssen.
Eier und Selbstgebackenes
verkaufte Heidi Fuhrer
viele Jahre an einem Stand.
Danach richteten mir
meine Kinder einen Hofladen ein.
Das war immer mein Traum.
Aus meinem Stand wurde dieser Laden.
Das Geld, das ich mit dem Laden
und auf dem Markt verdiente,
wurde auch
in den Bauernhof investiert.
Es gab keine Trennung
zwischen meinem Einkommen
und dem meines Mannes.
Inzwischen ist Heidi Fuhrers Hofladen
zu einem veritablen Lebensmittelladen
mit Produkten vieler Bäuerinnen
geworden.
Was denkt sie darüber,
dass die Schwiegertochter
eine eigene Firma gegründet hat?
Ich finde es gut,
dass sie das so machen,
aber ich persönlich
bräuchte das nicht.
Ich lebe lieber nach dem Motto:
"Alles, was mir gehört,
gehört auch dir."
Immerhin hat sich Heidi Fuhrer
als Selbstständige
bei der AHV angemeldet.
Geht es dir gut?
- Ja, danke, und dir?- Ja.
Ohne dies und ohne Lohn gäbe es
keine eigene soziale Absicherung.
Gut, danke.
- Einen schönen Tag.
Danke, gleichfalls. Tschüss, Janine.
- Tschüss.
* Unbehagliche Klänge *
Das Leben von Françoise Marendaz
wäre sicher einfacher,
hätte sie sich als Bäuerin um
ihre soziale Absicherung gekümmert.
Nach 30 Jahren Ehe
trennte sie sich von ihrem Mann,
verliess den Hof und ihren Alltag.
Für mich war es sehr schlimm.
Ich hatte auf eine Art
alles zurückgelassen.
Es ging mir wirklich schlecht,
obwohl ich ja diejenige war,
die ging.
Ich war es, die ins Leere sprang.
Denn ich konnte einfach nicht mehr.
Ich musste eine Lösung finden.
Und dann ging ich einfach.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Von einem Tag auf den anderen
hatte sie keine Arbeit
und kein Einkommen mehr.
Ich hatte ja keine Erfahrung
und schon ein gewisses Alter.
Aber ich sagte mir: "Ich muss
daran glauben, dass ich es schaffe."
Eine Zeit lang tat ich
so ziemlich alles, um zu überleben,
ich servierte auch.
Ich versuchte, Arbeitslosen-
unterstützung zu bekommen,
aber nicht mal das war möglich,
da ich ja nie einen Lohn hatte.
Hätten Sie nicht finanzielle
Unterstützung vom Staat bekommen?
Ich hätte wohl schon etwas bekommen.
Aber dann holen sie es sich
ja wieder dort, wo sie können:
vermutlich auf dem Hof.
Das konnte ich nicht machen,
v.a. wegen meiner Kinder.
Für Françoise Marendaz ein Dilemma.
Sie fürchtete,
der Staat werde das Geld
irgendwie auf dem Hof zurückholen -
also dem künftigen Besitz
ihrer Söhne.
Diesen Loyalitätskonflikt
haben viele geschiedene Bäuerinnen.
Deshalb verzichten sie oft
auf ihre Rechte.
Françoise Marendaz
steckte in grossen Schwierigkeiten.
Nur schon eine Wohnung zu finden,
war fast unmöglich.
Mieten sind ja nicht gerade billig.
Aber ich hatte sehr viel Glück.
Man fragte mich nicht
nach dem Lohnausweis.
Man vertraute mir,
weil man mich kannte.
Zuerst wollte ich eine Wohnung,
die weiter weg ist vom Hof.
Aber es wurde überall
ein Lohnausweis verlangt.
Ich hatte nichts vorzuweisen.
So begann sie mit 55 Jahren
nochmals eine Ausbildung
und machte einen Abschluss
an einer Buchhaltungsschule in Vevey.
Dann machte sie sich selbstständig.
Ich habe Freunde,
die mir ihre Buchhaltung und
ihre Steuererklärung anvertrauten.
Es waren immer nur kurze Aufträge
zur Überbrückung.
Und so sagte ich mir,
dass ich mir einen Tritt
in den Hintern geben
und weitermachen musste.
Nun mache ich ein Diplom
in spezialisierter Buchhaltung.
Es ist schwierig, aber ich muss
das nun einfach durchziehen
und dann sehe ich weiter.
Sind Sie stolz auf sich?
Ja, ich bin zufrieden mit mir.
Ich hoffe, dass es klappen wird.
Aber ich bin zufrieden mit mir.
So kann ich noch unabhängiger sein.
Aber natürlich werde ich
nicht in Pension gehen können.
Alors ...
* Dynamische Klänge *
Von solchen Situationen
haben die Bäuerinnen endgültig genug.
Sie möchten, dass ihre Arbeit
anerkannt und bezahlt wird.
Dort beginnt der politische Kampf
der Bäuerinnen.
Ihre Sprecherin in Bern
ist Anne Challandes,
Präsidentin des Schweizer
Bäuerinnen- und Landfrauenverbandes
und auch Vizepräsidentin
des Bauernverbandes.
Die Neuenburgerin
ist erst die zweite Frau
im Vorstand
des Schweizer Bauernverbandes.
Anne Challandes
hat über den Bauernverband
eine nationale Sensibilisierungs-
kampagne gestartet-
Die Kampagne thematisiert die
soziale Absicherung der Bäuerinnen.
Es geht um Sozialversicherungen,
Rente,
das Aufteilen des Einkommens
und um Lösungen bei Scheidungen.
Ich hoffe,
dass sich die Situation der Frauen
in den Landwirtschaftsbetrieben
klar verbessert,
sei es auf juristischer Ebene
oder bezüglich Sozialversicherungen
und Vorsorge.
Den Frauen sollte bewusst werden,
dass sie das Recht haben,
Ansprüche zu formulieren.
Aber dieses Bewusstsein
muss auch die Männer erreichen,
die ja oft die Chefs
auf den Betrieben sind.
Sie müssen verstehen,
dass sie eine Verantwortung haben
gegenüber ihren Mitarbeitenden.
Anne Challandes arbeitet seit
30 Jahren auf dem Hof ihres Mannes
in Fontainemelon.
Sie ist zuständig
für die Verwaltung des Betriebs,
für die Buchhaltung
und für den Haushalt.
Die Anwältin gab eine viel-
versprechende Karriere in Bern auf,
um Bäuerin zu werden.
Doch auf ihrem Hof
lief einiges schon immer anders.
So bekam Anne Challandes
von ihrem Mann
schon nach kurzer Zeit
einen Lohn.
Wenn eine Frau auf den Hof kommt
und arbeitet,
dann ist es schwierig,
diese Arbeit zu bemessen.
Oft macht sie Arbeiten,
die keinen Namen haben,
aber es sind dennoch Arbeiten.
Es ist auch eine Form
der Anerkennung dieser Arbeiten,
zu sagen:
"Dort hast du die Verantwortung."
"Ende das Jahres ziehen wir Bilanz
und deine Arbeit wird bezahlt."
Anne Challandes setzt sich dafür ein,
dass alle Bäuerinnen
eine Entschädigung erhalten.
Dafür müsse man das Recht
nicht neu erfinden.
Man kann das Einkommen des Hofes
aufteilen.
Der Partner
muss dann einfach bei der AHV
als selbstständig angemeldet sein.
Oder man kann einer Partnerin
einen Lohn auszahlen,
dann ist sie
eine bezahlte Angestellte.
Diese Möglichkeiten gibt es
im Obligationenrecht bereits.
Das ist kein Problem.
Man muss sich einfach für eine der
beiden Möglichkeiten entscheiden.
Doch noch gilt es, den Bauernverband
von der Dringlichkeit zu überzeugen.
Dort anerkennt man zwar,
dass die Bäuerinnen besser
abgesichert werden müssen,
aber man will sich auf keinen Fall
auf zwingende Verpflichtungen
einlassen.
Kann man nicht einfach
einen Lohn auszahlen?
Ja, klar, das kann man machen.
Und die Landwirte sollten es tun.
Aber man muss sie davon überzeugen,
sie motivieren.
Man muss ihnen sagen,
dass es auch in ihrem Interesse ist,
wegen der Steuern und der Vorsorge.
Motivieren ja, verpflichten nein,
ist die Devise des Bauernverbandes.
Yvonne Koller Renggli,
die Ausbildungsverantwortliche des
Bäuerinnen- und Landfrauenverbandes,
ist optimistisch, dass sich die
Situation für die Frauen verbessert.
Den jungen Frauen, die ich
in der Ausbildung kennenlerne,
ist das bewusst.
Sie sind teils Treuhänderinnen
oder Ärztinnen.
Es hat sich sicher viel verändert.
In der Generation unserer Eltern
hatten die Frauen oft keinen Beruf
und arbeiteten daher ohne
jegliche Absicherung im Betrieb.
Yvonne Koller Renggli,
selbst Bäuerin,
hat Verständnis
für die Situation auf den Höfen.
Als Ausbildungsverantwortliche hat
sie das Thema soziale Absicherung
in den Schulen ins Zentrum gerückt.
Unsere Ausbildung,
Bäuerin mit Fachausweis,
wird von jungen Frauen
sehr gut besucht.
Wir machen die Frauen
auf das Thema aufmerksam
und empfehlen ihnen,
sich ihre rechtliche Situation
und ihre soziale Absicherung
auf dem Betrieb anzuschauen.
Kampagnen können ermutigen,
doch es ist nicht immer einfach,
Ansprüche anzumelden.
Noch dazu, wenn mehrere Generationen
auf einem Hof leben.
Es hängt ein bisschen
von den Familienstrukturen ab,
ob die jungen Frauen den Mut haben,
das Thema anzusprechen.
In unserer Ausbildung
vermitteln wir den Frauen jedoch,
dass ihr Gegenüber
in erster Linie ihr Partner ist.
Dort muss man ansetzen.
Sie müssen mit ihren Partnern reden,
sich trauen,
diese Dinge zu besprechen.
Dann sollte das andere der Sache
nicht mehr so sehr im Weg stehen.
* Ruhige Streicherklänge *
Kommt.
Öffnest du?
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge,
Krähen eines Hahns *
Roxane Perretten
ist heute Chefin ihres Betriebes.
Den Hof, auf dem sie geboren wurde,
übernahm sie aber erst nach
einem langen und schwierigen Weg.
Auch sie träumte davon,
Bäuerin zu werden.
Aber ihr Vater riet ihr davon ab,
aus Angst, dass sie es
finanziell nicht schaffen würde.
So machte sie
eine Lehre in einer Bank.
Viens, ma belle.
Es war schrecklich,
plötzlich eine Lehre zu beginnen,
mit dem Zug in die Stadt zu fahren,
nach Lausanne.
Ich kannte das überhaupt nicht.
Das ist viel für ein kleines Mädchen
von 15 Jahren,
v.a. wenn man aus einem kleinen
Paradies auf dem Land kommt.
Ich hatte hier
eine zauberhafte Kindheit.
Dann arbeitete ich dies und das.
Es gab Enttäuschungen und Ängste
in meinem Leben.
Das alles führte dazu,
dass ich zu viel Alkohol
und zu viele Drogen konsumierte.
2010 musste ich einen Entzug machen.
Irgendwann sagte ich: "Stopp."
* Vogelzwitschern,
melancholische Klänge *
Auf dem Hof der Familie
ist sie wieder zur Ruhe gekommen.
Ihre Eltern
haben sie immer unterstützt.
Doch die Zeit des Entzugs
war hart und lang.
In den Stall zu gehen mit meinem
Papa, der noch einige Kühe hatte,
tat mir wahnsinnig gut.
Die Meerschweinchen
halfen mir auch sehr.
Je sais ce que tu veux, mon gros.
Auf dem Hof ist man der menschlichen
Härte nicht ausgesetzt.
Auch wenn die Tage hart sind und
man nicht viel schläft in der Nacht.
Es ist egal. Für meine Tiere
stehe ich natürlich gerne auf.
Wenn meine Hühner
nicht zufrieden sind mit mir,
tun sie nicht so,
als wäre alles in Ordnung
und kritisieren mich nicht
hinter meinem Rücken.
So im Stil von:
"Hast du die da gesehen?"
Es ist viel einfacher.
Man muss sich nicht
25'000 Fragen stellen.
Man muss einfach machen.
Weil für sie der Hof und die Natur
so wichtig sind,
tauchte langsam die Idee wieder auf,
den Hof zu übernehmen.
Kurz darauf traf sie Guy Amigoni,
ihren Partner.
Wir haben uns auf absolut
verrückte Art kennengelernt.
Und wir hatten absolut
nicht vor, zusammenzuarbeiten.
Ich habe ihn wirklich
im richtigen Moment getroffen.
Er sagte: "Mach es doch einfach,
wenn es das ist, was du möchtest."
"Warum solltest du
das nicht können?"
Ich hätte es vielleicht nicht
gemacht, ohne diese Ermutigung.
Und ohne ihn.
Er sagte mir von Anfang an,
er werde mir helfen.
So schöpfte ich Vertrauen.
Ich war wirklich
etwas wütend auf Roxane,
weil sie mir
lange nicht gesagt hatte,
dass sie von einem Hof stammt.
Das war für mich ein Schock.
Denn tief in mir drin
hatte ich immer Lust,
etwas mit Landwirtschaft zu machen.
Heute kann ich es leben.
Dafür danke ich Roxane jeden Tag.
So übernahm Roxane Perretten
den Betrieb
und taufte ihn Hof der Verliebten.
Ihr Vater hilft mit den grossen
Weizen- und Rapsflächen.
Auch die Reben bleiben sein Reich.
* Krähen eines Hahns,
Vogelzwitschern *
Es sind die grossen Anbauflächen,
mit denen wir
im Moment Geld verdienen.
Aber am Ende des Jahres
sind wir nicht wirklich reich,
das muss ich sagen.
Deshalb denke ich schon,
dass wir auch
nach Alternativen suchen müssen.
Um ihre finanzielle Situation
zu verbessern,
wollen sich die beiden auf Pflanzen
und Tiere spezialisieren,
die vom Aussterben bedroht sind.
Also auf Arten, die von der Stiftung
ProSpecieRara unterstützt werden.
Ich denke, das ist eine Möglichkeit,
sich abzugrenzen.
So können wir Leute anziehen,
die auf der Suche
nach dieser Art von Produkten sind.
Deshalb haben wir nun für dieses
Jahr auch ein Permakulturprojekt.
Das ist unsere Art,
auf die finanziellen Schwierigkeiten
zu reagieren.
Wir erfinden uns jeden Tag neu
und lernen viel zusammen -
für unsere Beziehung
und für unsere Arbeit.
Mit der Arbeit auf dem Hof wurde
mir bewusst, dass ich eine Frau bin.
All die Dinge,
bei denen es um Kraft geht ...
Ich kann den besten Willen
der Welt haben,
aber mehr als 25 kg
kann ich nicht heben.
Guy trug ein kleines Kalb,
das bestimmt 50 kg wog.
Er nahm es auf die Schultern
und trug es bestimmt 400 m weit.
Eigentlich hätte ich
das machen sollen,
aber das war einfach unmöglich.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Anne Chenevard gehört
zu den Bäuerinnen und Bauern,
die sich dem Kampf für einen
fairen Milchpreis verschrieben haben.
Dies nach den Streiks der Bauern
2008 und 2009.
Le message est clair,
soyons solidaires.
Damals schon verlangten die Bauern
1 Fr. pro Liter
und damals schon
bekamen sie bloss 60 Rp.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Aber zehn Jahre später, nachdem der
Milchpreis auf 55 Rp. gefallen war,
schafften es Anne
und andere Milchproduzenten:
Sie erhielten endlich
den verlangten Franken pro Liter.
Auch wenn die Aktion nur einem Teil
der Milchproduzenten zugutekam:
Es war ein Durchbruch.
2019 kamen die ersten Milchpackungen
in den Läden an,
die für einen fairen Milchpreis
für die Bauern standen.
Das hat gezeigt, dass wir
fähig sind, Lösungen zu finden.
Wir müssen optimistisch sein.
Ich habe Vertrauen in die Zukunft.
Ich glaube, dass mein Betrieb
noch an viele Generationen
weitergegeben wird.
Trotz dieses Optimismus und des
Erfolgs mit dem fairen Milchpreis,
war es für Anne Chenevard
keine einfache Zeit.
Viel zu früh verstarb ihr Vater.
Auch wenn ihre Beziehung nicht nur
einfach war, weiss Anne Chenevard,
dass er zuletzt
all seine Hoffnungen in sie setzte.
* Muhen *
Ja, ich glaube, er war stolz.
Als er noch den Kampf
um den Milchpreis führte,
war der Moment
wahrscheinlich noch nicht reif.
Dann gelang es uns,
dieses Projekt umzusetzen,
das schon so lange im Raum stand.
Dass es nun eine Frau war, die
das geschafft hatte, bewegte ihn.
Es war nicht immer einfach.
Wenn man eine Tochter hat, müssen
die Eltern noch mehr beweisen,
dass sie genauso mutig ist
wie die Männer.
Aber er hat Ihnen
ja diesen Hof vermacht.- Oui.
Ist das auch Vaterliebe?
Ja, am Tag bevor er starb, sagte er:
"Anne, du wirst es schaffen."
Manchmal fehlt mir
das Selbstvertrauen.
Aber dann sage ich mir:
"Komm schon, wenn er an mich
glaubte, dann schaffe ich es auch."
Ab die Post.
Auf den meisten Höfen
herrscht noch die klassische
Rollen- und Aufgabenteilung.
Der Mann ist Betriebsleiter
und Hofbesitzer, die Frau Bäuerin.
Na? Oh, leckt sie dich ab?
- Bäh.
Hat sie dich erwischt?
Bist du ein bisschen nass? Was
machen wir, wenn du schmutzig bist?
Genau, so.
Auch Marina Fuhrer hat sich
entschieden, für Kinderbetreuung,
Haushalt und Buchhaltung
verantwortlich zu sein.
Doch als eine von inzwischen gut
30 % der Bäuerinnen in der Schweiz
erhält sie dafür einen Lohn.
Es ist einfach gerecht,
dass man dafür
auch einen Lohn erhält.
Dieses Problem
haben ja viele Frauen,
die wegen der Kinder
aufhören zu arbeiten -
auch solche,
die keine Bäuerinnen sind.
Man weiss nicht,
was die Zukunft bringt.
Wenn es irgendwann
zu einer Scheidung kommt ...
... will man nicht total
im Regen stehen.
Marina Fuhrer hat sich
auch für ihre Abschlussarbeit
mit ihrer Rolle als Bäuerin
auseinandergesetzt.
Die Quintessenz ist,
dass es einem gut gehen muss.
Daran arbeiten wir kontinuierlich.
Wir achten darauf, dass wir
nebst der Arbeit auf dem Betrieb
auch Zeit für uns als Paar
oder als Familie haben
und dass wir uns gelegentlich
eine Auszeit nehmen können.
Beat und ich
bringen Lorin am Samstag
z.B. manchmal zu meinen Eltern
und unternehmen gemeinsam etwas.
Wir gehen z.B. gern baden.
Wir achten darauf,
dass das immer
wieder mal möglich ist.
In den letzten 100 Jahren,
da sind sich die Bäuerinnen einig,
hat sich für Bauernfamilien
vieles geändert.
Vom Wellnessen konnten die Bäuerinnen
früher nur träumen.
Sie arbeiteten Tag und Nacht.
Ohne Maschinen und ohne Lohn,
ohne Mitsprache und ohne Anerkennung.
Oft gab es auf den Höfen
nicht einmal fliessendes Wasser.
Ich kontrolliere Lorin
jeweils auch hinter den Ohren.
Was für eine Bäuerin
ist sie Ihrer Meinung nach?
Sie ist eine moderne Bäuerin.
Es ist nicht wie bei uns,
aber das ist heutzutage so.
Im Stall und an anderen Orten
wurde ja auch vieles modernisiert.
Man muss gar nicht mehr
so viel mithelfen wie früher.
Heidi Fuhrer hat ihre Rolle
anders ausgefüllt als Marina.
Zeit für sich,
das gab es früher nicht.
Und etwas fällt ihr
ganz besonders auf.
Marina hat bestimmt
mehr Zeit für Lorin.
Ich hatte meine Kinder
bei der Arbeit einfach dabei.
Wenn ich die Kühe melkte,
sassen sie auf meinem Schoss.
Als sie noch kleiner waren,
setzte ich sie in einen Zuber.
Das war einfach so.
Heute muss
nicht mehr gemolken werden.
Das ist eine grosse Zeitersparnis.
Es ist schön,
dass man sich heute explizit
mit dem Kind beschäftigen kann
und es nicht immer
bei der Arbeit dabeihaben muss.
Danke. Super.
Nimmst du den?
Mit den Bäuerinnen
ändern sich auch die Bauern.
Einen Betreuungstag pro Monat
übernimmt Beat Fuhrer - immerhin.
Bist du bereit?
Ich denke, für eine Veränderung
braucht es immer beide.
Das Zusammenleben in der Familie
hat sich schon stark verändert
und wird sich noch mehr verändern.
Die übliche Rollenverteilung - der
Mann draussen und die Frau am Herd -
ist zwar noch stärker ausgeprägt
als an anderen Orten,
aber trotzdem nicht mehr so starr.
Dass sich der Mann
mal ums Kind kümmert
oder etwas mit dem Kind unternimmt,
wird gewiss auch
in der Landwirtschaft
immer öfter der Fall sein.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Viel Spass.
- Danke.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Die leise Revolution der Bäuerinnen
wird die Landwirtschaft prägen.
Im Girentobel hoffen sie,
dass noch viele Generationen
den Hof übernehmen werden -
Söhne oder Töchter.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Manuela Waldner - 2022